all right I got to tell you this story
you have a liberal law professor very
esteemed he's being ripped right now by
many on the left for writing an op-ed
that defended Supreme Court nominee
Brett Kavanaugh Akhil Reed amar is a
professor at Yale Law School and Todd
Cavanaugh when he was there after Judge
Cavanaugh his nomination was announced
he obviously was happy and he wrote a
piece for the New York Times stating
quote the liberal case for Cavanaugh and
calling him extremely qualified in
response progressive writers many of
them have been savaging them you want
some examples slate called this article
complete crap get GQ called is something
we cannot air but we can't air professor
amar he joins us right now professor you
knew when you wrote this that you get
some blowback did you expect something
like that maybe it was a little more
than I expected but it comes with the
territory I love the fact that this
country has robust uninhibited wide open
debate it's the glory of our society I
prefer that it sometimes be a little
less personal but but it ours is a
wonderful democracy why do you think a
somebody who's been labeled a perfect
judge by conservatives would do a good
job on the Supreme Court because I think
that a great judge is open-minded and
changes his or her mind sometimes and I
think I've seen those virtues in Brett
Kavanaugh a great judge is a scholar of
the Constitution a great justice in
particular because the Supreme Court
really focuses a lot on constitutional
issues and I think Brett Kavanaugh has
studied the Constitution deeply and I
think he's a person of good character
and willing and he's been willing to
admit he's made mistakes in the past
good an experienced person actually has
made mistakes and and a really good
judge or a leader learns from those
mistakes
so when you see Chuck Schumer declare
it's going to be end of the world the
end of roe v wade end of same-sex
marriage and of freedom of expression or
things like this what do you say to them
I'm a very staunch believer myself in a
constitutional right of same-sex
marriage I think Justice Kennedy as the
swing voter and
Burger Phil case got it right I should
remind the audience that have Brett
Kavanaugh clerked for Anthony Kennedy I
know them both well I admire them both
there are actually a lot of similarities
Justice Kennedy was a staunch believer
in free speech is a staunch believer
free speech whether it's of a
conservative sort citizens united or a
liberal sort a right to burn a flag I
think he was right in both of those
cases and I think that Brett Kavanaugh
is a staunch believer in freedom of
expression people even Jeffrey Toobin
said no one can say he's not qualified
you say if you're gonna vote no you tell
Democrats on Cavanaugh
publicly named at least two clearly
better candidates whom a Republican
president would really realistically
have nominated that's what got under
people's skin why does that work for you
well and your audience should know that
I supported Merrick garland I voted for
for Hillary Clinton but the way our
Constitution is set up it's a process in
which the president nominates the Senate
confirms ours is a two-party system
where one party controls both the
presidency and the Senate and as a
practical matter and has given us a list
of people that is that they have been
under strongly considered if you pick
someone else off the list who's better I
can't think of anyone or tell us why
it's an inadequate list professor you're
just saying these are the rules these of
low Wallace this is the Constitution
it's simple sorry you're getting this
backlash but welcome to our world
professor thanks so much for your time
thank you